[Applause]
[Music]
Scott this is the MV 1200 s uh no it's
the entry model for Mitsubishi does that
mean there's a big compromise no joke
from Mitsubishi we have a standard sort
of cook control that runs throughout the
range Mitsubishi is the second biggest
producer of controls worldwide so we try
to maintain that the high level starting
with the control the casting of the
machine tall runs through the range also
and really from there it's just subtle
smaller options where perhaps the the
machine is more orientated maybe towards
a small job sharp or small mold maker
and there may be options on the next
machine up that he may not require so
it's really maintaining the generator
capacity the threading capacity and
control that the operator needs so
there's no compromise on the end result
the S series actually for us in the UK
is our best selling machine tools the
customers really love it how about the
famous painted did technology of the
white automatic wire thread then yeah so
we're able to throw it dry
conventionally people would look to
thread a wet but the bit that the
problem with wet threading is if you've
got any tapered surface face or counter
bore or if you're trying to throw it
back down the slot it's not possible
with a water jet because the water jet
will deflect the wire by having a dry
throat er it means we can take 14 inches
of annealed wire and thread that back
down a slot or a more difficult
application now about the other
variables such as power consumption wire
consumption so the thing with the wire
consumption is we have something on the
technology called digital anti
electrolysis this moves the spark in
real time and allows us to give a more
even cut most people in the EDM field
will know that the one of their power
contactors tends to wear out before the
other and that's because the powers
distributed differently what the digital
anti electrolysis does is gets rid of
that but because it gets rid of that we
can also slow the wire speed down
considerably so we can see now when we
talk about rough cut situation 30%
increase in while I
so and the wire is your biggest running
cost on the wire machine technology just
because you've saved that down
there's no loss of productivity is there
no no we still maintain the cutting
speeds I think if there was going to be
any kind of compromise on coming speeds
we wouldn't go that way because at the
end of the day the customer needs to get
the part out as quickly as possible so
he can get the next job in and keep his
workflow moving I know it's got fiber
optic cables what's the advantage so the
fiber optic cables enable information to
be transmitted from the drive system to
the servo and backward and forward and
the reason for this is the EDM process
is all happening in microseconds and we
need to get the information back to the
control to make any a kind of adjustment
as quickly as possible so typically when
a machine tool operators may be cutting
20 or 30 millimeter thick material
that's quite a nice situation but what
we find with the Mitsubishi technology
is that the tall of the workpiece the
more steps in the workpiece more holes
in inside that's where Mitsubishi really
come into their own and part of that is
that the generator capability the
control and the communication to the
drives to prevent wire breakages I hear
a lot about the achieve of the drive
technology what is this
so the tubular drive technology is a
magnetic propulsion system
Mitsubishi looked for many years at flat
plate linear motor systems and there are
some advantages but there are some
disadvantages like heat being
transmitted into the into the machine
tool what they call cogging and the
tubular drive system does away with that
and uses 360 degrees of the flux so the
enforcers are and the magnets are
actually completely surrounded on the S
machine we used the tubular drive system
in the X and Y axis and then if we move
up to the next model the our system we
use the tubular drive in the U and V
also okay and how about warranties on
this machine it seems to me there's a
high level of technology for quite a low
cost space but how about the warranties
so Mitsubishi even when we were using
ball screws we're offering
a ten-year positional walk warranty and
that still applies to this machine when
you think about the U and V axis but
with what we now offer is a twelve-year
positional warranty throughout the range
of wire EDM machines so you say it's a
pop of the machine who's buying these
machines is it subcontractors or even
OEMs yeah a lot of subcontract little
job shops tool makers mold shops and I
think really that's just the general
technology offers itself you know quite
a diverse range we can cut a standard on
the on the S machine is from 0.1 to 0.3
wire which for most general job shops
covers a wide range of scope typical
surface finished on steel point three
five point four are a point three on
carbide which would satisfy most
people's needs another 1200 Scott to
vape op the machine I do see a lot of
these on my travels but how about the
rest of the range so in the S line we
also have the 2400 machine as I've
traveled 600 by 400 but in it has to
hike configurations so you can have a
310 fully submerged or 425 fully
submerged and then from there we can
move up to the MV 4800 it's a travel of
800 by 600 by 510 with a low capacity of
three tons on the table Scott on the HK
technology they exclusive dealer from
Mitsubishi DM but it's a business how
much experience have you got with this
type of technology so myself and my
colleague in applications between us we
have over 40 years experience in
applications plus time on the job in the
job shop or tall room and service
engineers also have more than 40 hits
between them so a wide range of
experience spanning over a wide range of
products so you've got the double whammy
you've got local support in the UK but
you've also got this facility behind you
when you need it yeah absolutely I think
when people are looking to buy a machine
and they see maybe a dealer that their
first thing is to thing they're not
dealing with the manufacturer but as you
can see today we have a very very close
relationship with the manufacturer
and quite often we were even coming here
and helping them out with their demos
and test carts as well as their customer
visits and presentations
[Music]